hello everyone and welcome to today's
broadcast best practice strategies and
tools for scaling clinical
bioinformatics it is presented by Elaine
G PhD the founder and president of big
head analytics group and Judi O'Rourke
of laberd's and I'll be your moderator
for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
labyrinth lab roots is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before I begin I'd like to
remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want anytime you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop down box it
appears on your screw the screen our
speaker will respond to your questions
via email if you have trouble seeing or
hearing the presentation please click on
the ask a question box to let us know
that you're having a problem this
presentation is educational and thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
G I will now turn the presentation over
to her thanks Judy it's my pleasure to
be here I would like to talk to you
today about the best practice strategies
and tools for scaling clinical biomedics
my name is Elaine G and I'm the founder
and principal consultant of big head
analytics group we provide consulting
services for clinical biomedics
applications the stop today will discuss
how to leverage compute infrastructure
to build a scalable clinical bi
informatics pipeline that is portable
maintainable and feature-rich according
to the Broad Institute genomic data is
doubling in size every eight months
compute infrastructure today has
advanced since the early stages were
mainframes where the main the main
source of computation these computers
were the size of large rooms and ran off
of punch cards that typically held 80
characters per card computer programs
are first stored in the mid-seventies on
these write-once cards that required a
deck of
to run a computer program fast-forward
to almost 50 years later when we now
have enabled both read and write
capabilities for data storage when that
Lobby markets came when the floppy disk
came on to market he's allowed for
read/write capabilities off of a
mechanical device which could start up
to a whopping 1.2 megabytes of data 30
years later in the tooth in the late
2000s the USB flash drive came along and
could now store much larger volumes of
data on the order of 2 to 512 gigabytes
per drive this capacity allowed for
smaller faster faster and durable
storage in the pursuit of precision
medicine in order to better diagnose
treat and monitor disease the search for
molecular targets has required complex
bioinformatics infrastructure single
gene assays have evolved into multi gene
evaluations in order to efficiently
evaluate multiple molecular targets
simultaneously in a recent study that
was published this year as of August
2017 it was estimated that of the 75,000
genetic test offerings that were
available in the market fourteen percent
of these were panel tests and 1.2
percent of these tests were whole exome
sequencing more importantly this paper
showed that the rate of new tests
emerging on the market was on average
ten new tests per day where two to three
of these tests were panel tests
indicating that there was a need for
better copy power as well as data
storage sequencing technology has been
becoming cheaper over time and this is
evident in terms of how genetics
sequencing has been scaling in less than
two decades the scale sequencing has
grown from one genome to a million
genomes from the first human genome
project that started in 2001 2003 using
the first hierarchical shotgun
sequencing technology the ability for
scientists to determine the human genome
sequence was a major achievement they
were able to cover about 90% of the
genome with four to 5x coverage in the
first draft that was published in 2001
since then sequencing technology has
been scaling orders of magnitude with
each new study that has come aboard
as a 2008 the thousand genome project
scaled by three orders of magnitude to
cover 2,500 four genomes two short years
later at the UK 10k project they scaled
yet again by an order of magnitude to
cover 10,000 patients where 40% of these
patients were sequence across their
entire genome two years later in 2012
the genomics England project scaled yet
again an order of magnitude to a hundred
thousand genomes today the NIH has
started a new study called all of us
which aims to sequence 1 million genomes
in order to support 1 million samples
from a clinical bioinformatics
perspective this requires a scalable
bioinformatics ecosystem in order to
achieve a million samples the NIH had
requested that genome centers could
process 200,000 samples a year this is
equivalent to want processing one genome
every three minutes as you can imagine
this would require a highly scalable ran
chromatic ecosystem in order to process
this number of samples in this short of
time in order to achieve this scale we
need to optimize the bioinformatics
pipeline development across three major
parts of the pipeline development cycle
the first step is to optimize on the
pipeline development side the second is
to ensure high quality clinical
bioinformatics through pipeline testing
and quality assurance and lastly to also
scale at the stage of pipeline staging
and develop and deployment because the
clinical by informatics product life
cycle is something that is literate of
requiring constant technical
implementation this cycles around and
repeats itself as each new features
released typically clinical by
informatics teams may not necessarily be
formally trained in clinical
bioinformatics because this is such a
new field many of the contributors who
work in clinical bioinformatics
typically build scientific software in
an ad hoc fashion because they may not
necessarily be a classically trained
computer scientists or software
engineers
they typically come from backgrounds
best buying in biology as well as
mathematics and may not necessarily be
professional software engineers in this
paper that was published in 2011 they
summarized some typical symptoms that
are common of ad hoc scientific software
development some typical issues include
it's almost finished this pipelines not
maintained anymore the programmer has
left the lab this program doesn't work
this function is not documented and it
doesn't compile on my machine from a
clinical by informatics perspective ad
hoc software with these types of
symptoms are unacceptable and also limit
the ability to scale your ecosystem so
today I'm going to convince you to that
leveraging best practice tools and
strategies will allow you to scale your
by kromaggs pipeline without sacrificing
quality here is a cartoon from xkcd
which highlights and makes pokes fun at
the ability to utilize best practices on
the left it says I could restructure the
programs flow or just use one little
go-to instead a scoop good practice how
bad can it be
compile on the right you can see what
happened so this cartoon is all in good
fun but it actually does highlight an
issue that had arisen not that long ago
back in 2014 there was a go to bug in
the Apple iOS system that exposed an SSL
security vulnerability where duplicate
go to fail statement in their program
allowed for an authenticated access to a
given program because of this
duplication and that go to command the
security system of the program was no
longer providing the needed SSL
authentication tools like unit tests and
others tests that I'll talk about later
in this talk today can help to reduce
these types of errors from propagating
into your production pipeline in my talk
but my goal is to give you a high-level
outline of how best practices and
software engineering and DevOps DevOps
methodologies can be integrated into
your
dramatic platformer the session is
intended to introduce the audience to
modern technologies for application
development and deployment that is
relevant to the clinical practice of
bioinformatics informatics technology
must be kept up in order to scale and to
handle new analysis as it comes in
whether it be including unique molecular
kind of identifiers incorporating
analytics to support low levels of
detection for circulating cell-free DNA
applications or to handle the growing
databases of information that's required
for annotation in order to perform
clinical interpretation the goal is to
create value through automation and
software infrastructure with your
bioinformatics platform so in order to
handle large volumes of data the by
informatics can take advantage of
automation at many levels of your
platform from resource optimization
continuous integration as well as
orchestration management and this talk
will focus on describing mechanisms to
support each of these levels through
workflow engines testing frameworks
containerization and operation
intelligence by integrating
standardization and automation at these
levels you can achieve scaleable
clinical bioinformatics platforms today
will be a general introduction to the
key concepts and fundamentals of a scale
scalable bioinformatics ecosystem which
will focus on automating at many levels
I'll discuss using software engineering
techniques and best practices to create
a robust and scalable infrastructure the
support the detail analysis work was
required for NGS based genetic tests
will focus on scaling bioinformatics by
leveraging infrastructure to build a
scalable and portable modern by
informatics pipeline to use testing
frameworks and containers to facilitate
validation of a bio Franck's pipeline
and to review some tools for real-time
pipeline and compute infrastructure
monitoring and production from this talk
we'll achieve the following learning
objectives we'll be able to understand
how to design a modern bio Frye's
pipeline using a workable framework use
get to manage software versions
throughout the bio 4x development
lifecycle set up a continuous
integration environment to improve the
quality
of code change in grade into a bi
chromatic software during development
use container technology to achieve
pipeline reproducibility and
interoperability between compute
platforms and apply current by for my
acceleration guidelines to biomedics
compute infrastructure this top will not
cover deep topics of security or privacy
or could be a comprehensive outline of
how to validate such an infrastructure
there are solutions that are
commercially available for off-the-shelf
buy informatics that take advantage of
some of these technologies described in
this talk but the details outlined here
are relevant for building in-house
solutions I will also not focus on
describing the expertise required in
terms of FTE requirements for building
this infrastructure but instead will
highlight the advantages and utility of
each piece of technology from the
context of building a scalable clinical
by informatics infrastructure in this
talk I will also use examples based on
Python but concepts can be generalized
to other common languages additionally
this talk will not describe recommended
tools for sequence alignment and variant
calling or other by informatics tools
before we develop the back from X
pipeline it's important to understand
the future requirements defined by the
clinical utility of your assay before we
get started I would like to review a
couple of poll questions if you have
time to answer the first poll question
is to cover which of these aspects of
mine Frank's development is most
challenging for your team any scaling
performance be achieving faster
development cycles or C implementing
validations the second poll question
will cover what part of your bio from a
nice pipeline needs the most work to
scale is it a the analytical pipeline B
validation or C compute infrastructure
and data storage and lastly how many
samples does your by premised pipeline
support in a week less than 50 50 to 500
or greater than 500 please consider
these questions as you think about how
to scale your bioinformatics ecosystem
let's first automate at the level of
pipeline development in order to help
this help to scale our my informatics
ecosystem it's important to set the
foundation for scalability at the level
pipeline development by applying
key concepts summarized here today we'll
talk about imparting scalability through
workflow engines using interactive
computing environments as well as to
take advantage of parallel development
using version control and tools like git
flow first we can talk about how to
automate your pipeline execution using a
workflow engine on the right you'll see
that there is a section of code shown
that it describes a rule called a line
with bwa a workflow engine allows for
Standardization of your by for max
pipeline by clearly delineating the
inputs outputs commands parameters as
well as compute parameters needed to run
your specific analytics on the left is a
table showing a summary of various types
of workflow engines that can be utilized
to develop your bi informatics pipeline
it summarizes the ease of development
the ease of use as well as performance
considerations more specifically a
workflow engine is comprised of multiple
rules that are chained together as shown
on the bottom right a workflow engine
not only standardizes each of these
analytic rules analytic steps into rules
but also displays the workflow in a
graphic called this directed acyclic
graph on the bottom this dag also allows
for the user to understand how data
provenance is maintained throughout your
by Franks type line by clearly showing
how inputs and outputs feed into each
role that comprises your entire
bioinformatics pipeline so for example
this aligned with BW a rule is the first
step of this pipeline and is defined by
inputs that require the first two files
as well as commands and for bwa as well
as the human reference it also defines
what type of outputs are generated from
this rule and how it feeds into the
other commands by providing a shell
command the parameters that are defined
in both your configurations as well as
within the rule can be used to run bwa
and controlling the threads using the
thread command within this rule set
allows for this workflow to be scaled
across any concrete platform
second we were going to talk about
interactive computing environments such
as Jupiter this allows you to document
as you go during the pipeline
familiarization and optimization process
here is an example of a paper that was
published in plus computational biology
these authors provided Jupiter notebooks
to show how they generated the figures
that were published in their paper this
type of document as you go methodology
can be applied to the development of
your bio Fricks pipeline by allowing for
side-by-side documentation of both the
code that generates the analytics as
well as human language to interpret how
the analytics was done so here's an
example of the Jupiter notebook that was
used to generate figure supplementary
figures three in this plus computational
biology paper as you can see at the top
there is a title that describes the
purpose of this notebook as well as the
description of the downstream analysis
at a really high level each section of
code is known as a code block and is
labeled by the number in which it was
executed in order to generate the
downstream outputs as we move down you
can see that there's a detail of the
normalization algorithm that was used to
generate the plot below as well as the
corresponding code block that performed
the normalization analytics skipping
through a couple of code blocks you can
see that at the end of your Jupiter
notebook when it's run it will generate
the output from the entire notebook and
in this case this is the supplementary
figure that was found in the paper by
applying this type of methodology this
will allow for by for my skype lines to
be built as well as document documented
at the same time this will help during
the familiarization optimization process
as well as downstream documentation
that's needed for validation and lastly
I'd like to talk about scaling pipeline
development using software version
control and branching and merging
strategies here's an example of how a
potential get flow could be used in
order to leverage the number of
resources that are on your biomedics
team so typically a branching strategy
understanding the differences between
the various branches that exists
typically the continuous branches known
as dev and prod are continuously in
existence in order to represent the
source code changing that exists during
development as well as what is used in
production typically the production
branch will contain the code that was
released into your clinical
bioinformatics environment that is used
to process after the pipeline's have
been validated so to orient you if you
look on the dev branch there during the
pipeline development cycle by the end of
the feature development there will be a
release candidate that's identified when
this release can't candidate or RC is
identified the corresponding source code
is migrated over to the test branch this
test branch will be used to evaluate
whether or not the pipeline can be
properly validated and if there's any
issues or bugs that are identified
during the testing these bugs will be
fixed in the dev branch and re-released
to the test branch if the validation
completes successfully this tested
and/or validated version of the bio
franks pipeline can then be released a
prod as version 1.0.0 so let's say
you're in production and an issue has
occurred where there's a bug that needs
to be fixed immediately and so you can
branch off what is called a hotfix
branch which will then take the commit
that has been released in production and
a bipartition shown here in red can work
on the bug that was identified and
commit code changes back to the test
environment to be tested once the
particulars code changes have been
validated and approved then these code
changes can be released to the version
10.1 in the production branch as well as
also merged back into the development
branch to keep the code in sync so
during this whole process there are two
other back partitions shown here in blue
and green we're working on the next set
of features to be released in the next
version of the pipeline so during this
time they've been working on the
released version of the
and branch and committing changes in
order to allow for these features to
occur over time they will also be able
to incorporate good bug fixes from the
hot chicks branch provided by the brand
transitions shown in red in gender code
so that when they are done and complete
they can push their changes to the dev
branch so that a cycle of testing and
production relations can continue this
concept of git flow described here can
allow for multiple by transitions to
work on the same source code base
simultaneously on various versions at
the same time this will allow for bug
fixes excuse me that fix is addressed to
handle any issues that arise in
production as well as to also a lot for
asynchronous development of new features
to be released in the next version of
the pipeline now we will talk about
automating at the next level so here
we're talk about pipeline quality
control and using testing frameworks to
allow for automation in order to scale
the first level of testing typically is
comprised of the unit tests this allows
us to perform detailed testing on our
Micromax pipeline to ensure that the
appropriate quality is there here's an
example of a really simple scripture
that's displays how a VCF could be read
this function read VCF can be developed
in order to process incoming outputs
from a variant caller for example in
this case in order to identify that the
function performs appropriately the unit
test can be just defined by testing
various use cases which can multiple in
nature as well as particular edge cases
that Magnus that may require evaluation
so for example one particular edge case
may be testing whether or not the
function properly handles an MT VCF some
use case testing that could happen is to
ensure that your pipeline is properly
reading sniz in those structural
variants as well as other types of
complex variants that may typically be
represented through symbolic notation or
other version types
the VCF by using unit tests to perform
the detailed testing of various use and
edge cases this ensures the developer
that the clinical by Fry's pipeline is
performing as expected additionally a
layer on top of the unit test is what is
known as an integration test shown here
on the left is the same tag that I
introduced in the workflow framework
discussion earlier as you can see a
clinical buy from Attucks pipeline is
quite complicated where there are
various aspects of your workflow that
have been paralyzed as shown by the
repeated rule sets for example in the
first half of the workflow that then
converged into downstream rules in order
to generate the final set of variant
calls for human interpretation because
these rules integrate together in a
complex fashion it's important to
perform an end-to-end evaluation using
integration tests so typically an
integration test is less detailed as
what was described for unit tests but
allow for the user to test certain file
types being processed by your entire
workflow and to ensure that it properly
identifies the variants expected so for
example a bio franks pipeline can be
broken down into four major functional
groups to cover d multiplexing and base
calling read mapping and processing
variant calling as well as variant
annotation and filtering by pushing
through specific files and folder sets
we can look at the output of your
pipeline to see if this and Dellin
structural variant calling is as
expected by performing this end-to-end
evaluation we can be confident that the
clinical by 4x pipeline is can be
executed and to end sufficiently despite
the complexity of the underlying rule
sets within the workflow engine the
third level of automation and
standardization will encompass pipeline
packaging validation and delivery we can
congeries the pipeline for scaleable
deployment a container typically allows
for certain features to exist so if you
look at the right side of the slide
you'll see that
can provide flexibility they are
lightweight as compared to virtual
machines they're interchangeable and
portable meaning that they can be
executed on various compute platforms
while maintaining the same type of
execution within the application and
because they are containerized they
allow for the scaling of your
application by deploying these
containers and they're stackable to
allow for distributed computing
applications to be developed one vendor
that's popular is the Decker container
which allows for open source use of the
containerization technology so if you
look to the left a docker container is
typically built out of a file called the
docker file the docker file defines the
type of environment that is to be
installed into your container as well as
maps any external ports that are
necessary to allow for reference files
or input files to be consumed by your
docker container these docker file files
are then built in order to generate an
image and this image contains the code
the runtime environment such as Python 3
any necessary libraries and what your
applications are dependent on
description of any environmental
variables that are needed for execution
of your application and configuration
files that can be defined that can
parametrize your climate called pipeline
the nice thing about these images is
that they can be tagged and published in
a very similar way to the source code
that we describe with git by tagging and
publishing your images they can be
stored into a registry that can either
be made public or private from this
registry provides a central repository
that can be used in which these
containers can be pulled and run on a
specific compute node so you can imagine
by centralizing these images into a
repository or registry that can be used
to pull down containers you can start to
think about computer environments that
can be scaled according to your sample
volume that then utilizes containers for
execution of your biomedics pipeline in
a consistent fashion
as we start to scale it's important to
maintain high quality pipelines by
utilizing some tools like this
continuous integration framework the
continuous integration environment
utilizes an automation server to perform
three major tasks of building testing
and deploying your bio informatics
pipeline by utilizing the continuous
integration framework it will trigger
builds each time a commit is made to a
specified branch this allows for testing
to happen before the source code change
is integrated into the major branches of
your repository so this allows for a bug
detection to occur much more quickly
because code that it is committed that
generates downstream bugs are identified
early on this allows for the code to be
kept in a deployable fashion at any
point in time because the code changes
that are integrated into your main
branches have been tested for bugs now
of course the continuous integration
environment is only as good as the unit
tests and integration tests that I
talked about before without thorough
testing development the continuous
integration environment may not
necessarily be effective so now that
we've talked about how to build and test
containers with each source code change
we can talk about how to deploy these
containers at scale and we do this using
orchestration management tools on the
top left I summarized a few examples of
orchestration management tools either
built-in and dodging ously with docker
swarm and stack deploy or using other
frameworks like kubernetes that are
based out of the Google container engine
and also implemented in Azure as the
kubernetes service there are other
orchestration management tools that are
also popular including Apache mazes and
the Amazon elastic container service in
AWS the basic concept of an
orchestration management management tool
is that it deploys your docker
containers on any new worker nodes that
are spun up a master node can use to
provision any new worker node that's
brought on to your computer cluster so
as I mentioned before the docker
containers can be stored in
trusted registry and by spinning up the
worker knows the masternode can
communicate to the new worker node which
container to pull down and to run on its
compute resources this allows for a
scaling of your compute environment by
spinning up or spinning down worker
nodes as the sample volume changes
here's an example of a compute
infrastructure that is openly available
that allows 4x4 max ecosystem to scale
by leveraging workflows and containers
the fire cloud is a system platform that
has been built at the Broad Institute as
you can see this allows for various
pipelines to be run and it takes
advantage of this Whittle workflow in
order to execute the by Frye's pipelines
these Whittle workflows are stored in
docker containers and executed on the
Carmel engine using batch execution and
taking advantage of the pipeline's API
on Google cloud allows for these direct
containers and workflows to be run on
the Google compute engine so the tools
that I've talked about so far for
Standardization automation can be
leveraged to help with performing
validations this can allow for
addressing various features of an
analytic validation that's required for
the bioinformatics pipeline recently
there's been published a validation
guide set of guidelines that summarizes
17 major guidelines and recommendations
to be addressed during bioinformatics
validation by leveraging the
standardization automation tools we can
allow for the analytic validation to be
accurate robust reproducible traceable
secure and compliant for example in
order to support accuracy the
interactive computing environment allows
for documentation during the Filner is a
ssin optimization steps as well as
taking advantage of the unit tests and
integration tests to ensure that
functionality is appropriate to make
these pipelines robust the continuous
integration environment takes advantage
of
unit tests and integration tests to
ensure that the function is there as
well as the workflow engines allow for a
standardization as well as scalability
within your bank's pipeline
containerization allows for these
pipelines to be robust and reproducible
by providing version control on your
pipeline as well as storage in a central
location of your source code in a
central repository or registry the
workflow engines also help with
providing traceability your dad
visualization of your inputs and outputs
throughout the rules set of rules that
are required for a given by Frank's
pipeline as well as generates
infrastructure logs that can be reviewed
security is provided through roles and
security groups in your compute
infrastructure as well as allowing for
real-time monitoring of these logs to
see if your pipeline is performing as
desired and lastly interactive computing
continuous integration and verging and
version control also allow for
compliance through documentation lastly
I'd like to focus on how to monitor
pipelines and production at scale and
we'll do this by speaking about
real-time monitoring software tools
operation intelligence tools give
real-time insight into operations into
your compute environment let's say on
the left you have a compute environment
that's comprised of master nodes worker
nodes as well as databases they may be
on-premise they may be in the cloud or a
hybrid version of the to these operation
intelligence tools like Splunk allow for
the user to have a single pane of glass
visualization as shown on the right a
various aspects of your compute
infrastructure this will allow for
observation of various logs as well as
allow for the user to set up warnings or
alerts depending on changes that are
unexpected from the performance of your
pipeline some of these operation
intelligence tools requires knowledge of
specific language query language in
order to develop these alerts and
notifications but they provide your
system administrator the ability to have
a single overarching view of the
performance of your
pipeline to Lao or the administrator to
understand if there's been any security
breaches or performance failures when
jobs are executed on those that scale
lastly I'd like to highlight a couple of
other considerations to consider when
building a modern by-products ecosystem
that I will not cover in detail today
these aspects can cover various designs
for data storage to efficiently query as
well as share genomic information this
impacts how the data sharing interfaces
can be designed to allow for scalable
data sharing for your clients there's
also considerations when it comes to
processing large volumes of genetic
information by applying big data
techniques such as Hadoop or MapReduce
and then lastly the ability to design
new tools using artificial artificial
intelligence techniques such as machine
learning algorithms to query across
these large datasets efficiently to gain
new insights relevant for variant
interpretation so in summary we were
able to review various aspects of modern
bio Mattox platform that will impart
scalability throughout your bio formatic
ecosystem we discussed the four major
levels in which the scalability can be
applied from pipeline development to
pipelines in production including
aspects of quality control packaging
validation and delivery and with this we
discussed tools for a resource
optimization with workflow engines
continuous integration to automatically
check for breaking changes when source
code commits are performed as well as
strategies for container izing your
pipeline and deploying these containers
using orchestration management tools and
lastly to achieve final scalability we
talked about real-time operation
intelligence tools for monitoring
performance of many of their nodes at
once
so I hope now I've convinced you that
you are one step closer to building a
modern bioinformatics ecosystem and
here's my last xkcd cartoon that
describes how someone who has
self-taught may now necessarily consider
reading a style guide in their
development I hope you also feel
empowered to explore these tools in more
detail in your own clinical by
informatics platform I'd like to thank
you all for your attention and I
appreciate your attending my talk again
my name is Elaine G and here's my email
address as well as my social media
handles if you'd like to reach out to me
for any additional questions thank you
for your time thank you dr. G for that
informative presentation we will now
start the Q&A portion of the webinar and
we'll address some of the most commonly
asked questions by our viewers if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the ask a
question drop-down box located on the
far left of your presentation window
have your question into the box that
appears on your screen and click on the
send button our speaker will follow up
with your questions via email so let's
get started
first question is I have a small
bioinformatics team to work with what's
the best place to start in order to
scale at our institution Thanks that's a
great question I think it depends on
where your needs are of course the most
important aspect of developing a bi
premised pipeline it's is validation so
I would recommend looking at your
validation process and understanding
what limitations are most urgent and
then to go back and to consider whether
workflow engines containerization or you
know testing your integration testing
could help benefit that validation
process thank you okay next one is my
team does not have formal training in
software development it's without formal
training yes that's a great question as
well so as I mentioned earlier lot of
automatic teams are firmly trained in
software engineering or software best
practices as an example I was formerly
the director of bio
and the team that I worked with also had
a very similar background in terms of
formal training with that team we
basically enabled the individuals to
perform the education required on the
job and they were able to design with
appropriate leadership a Elastic Compute
infrastructure that can now scale the
support of NGOs essays a Terry P thanks
next one is which workflow language is
best to start with so typically in the
clinical blank Romantics ergonomics
industry python is a popular programming
language because it's really easy to use
as well as has support for many
libraries that are necessary to perform
the analytics required it also has a
significant number of libraries if
you're looking to design machine
learning algorithms and many workflow
engine frameworks that are designed in
Python as well
Thanks looks like we have time for one
more question what part of the
bioinformatics pipeline do i
containerize that's a great question in
this case I would recommend looking at
the use cases in which you're developing
a bi informatics pipeline for and
depending on the reusability that's
necessary within your bio for Mike's
pipeline I would recommend splitting
your workflows or pipelines into
containers using those breaks so that
you can repeat the functional analysis
required by those containers in any type
of downstream application I would like
to once again thank dr. G for her
presentation but also like to thank lab
roots for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through February 15th 2019 you'll
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay we share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's event that's all
for now thank you for joining us we hope
to see you again soon goodbye